fake news it's a term we've heard
countless times over the last year or so
it's a term that is sometimes used
correctly but it's also been used
haphazardly and incorrectly so many
times that it has started to lose its
meaning when it hits our ears so I want
to clear the air about what fake news
actually is and what it is not and also
talk about what we can do to fight back
against it fake news is an intentional
misrepresentation of reality under the
guise of being truth an exaggeration a
distortion a flat-out lie
dressed up as the real news it can take
many different forms hoaxes slander any
kind of falsehood being circulated as
though it's accurate information often
for commercial political or ideological
reasons it's different from opinions and
editorials which are categories of
journalism that are not necessarily
dishonest on purpose those are often
based in reality using valid truthful
information that's then framed or spun
in some way like in the cases of
Breitbart or Fox News fake news is
distinct from that fake news is unique
because it deliberately aims to deceive
it uses inaccurate information knowing
that it's inaccurate hoping that the
person receiving the message will take
the claims to be true and credible fake
news can be quite profitable for
instance during the 2016 presidential
election Americans began paying much
more attention to politics and the
public became much more politically
polarized as is usually the case during
presidential elections the average
person began discussing government and
politicians much more with their friends
Facebook and Twitter feeds became filled
with political comments and links to
news stories Hillary Clinton this Donald
Trump that it was the perfect time for
an emergence of fake news and that's
what happened last year an effective way
to draw people to your website in order
to make more money from the ads on your
website is by posting fake news articles
with i grabbing sensational headlines
clickbait donald trump protester speaks
out I was paid 3500 dollars to protest
Trump's rally FBI leak Hillary Clinton
datian guilty of treason it doesn't
matter to the people writing and
publishing these articles that the info
is totally bogus because if they have
more people clicking on their links
they're making more money publishing
fake news can also be motivated by
political goals such as promoting a
candidate making a certain government
look good
gaining support for one side of a war
etc after Malaysian Airlines flight 17
was shot down in Ukraine in 2014 by
russia-backed separatists using Russian
missile launchers the Russian government
published an array of disinformation
fake news denying that Russia or the
separatists were responsible blaming it
on the Ukrainian government and the West
a perfect example of fake news but fake
news in essence is nothing new as long
as humans have had ways of disseminating
information there has been fake news
many people would characterize the Bible
merely as fiction or literature but you
can also think of it as news religious
scripture is written with the intention
of making people think that it's true
that it's an account of events that
actually occurred
the word gospel comes from the old
english word Godspell meaning good news
and if you assume that supernatural
phenomena do not occur that moses didn't
really speak to a burning bush or part
the Red Sea or that Jesus didn't really
turn water into wine and come back to
life after dying then somewhere along
the way in each individual instance
somebody somewhere had to make it up and
tell someone else or write it down
presumably knowing that it wasn't
literally true the Bible the Koran and
other religious texts are fake news that
have survived through today imagine if
you saw a fake news article in your
Facebook feed with the headline version
gives birth to the son of the creator of
the universe and then 2,000 years from
now people were still citing the article
but if you put a story like that into
the context of middle-eastern antiquity
where there was no literacy science or
journalism you can see why it gained
traction in the sixth century AD the
busy
tene historian procopius manufactured a
great deal of fake information referred
to as anecdote uh in order to defame the
byzantine emperor justinian fake news
procopius didn't admit to doing this
until he was on his deathbed in 1475 in
trent italy a two and a half year old
boy named Seema Nino went missing and a
catholic priest named Bernard Ino da
fell today began giving sermons in the
city saying that Jews had kidnapped the
child murdered him and drained his blood
to celebrate Passover none of this was
true but the fake news spread quickly
and it led to the city's Jewish
community being arrested and tortured
and 15 of the Jews were burned at the
stake and the situation inspired other
nearby towns to do the same to their
Jews to this day there are anti-semitic
websites saying that the made-up story
about the Jews killing the child was
true also in Italy in 1522
a writer named Pietro Ida the--not
manipulated the papal election by
writing falsehoods about all of the
candidates except for the one that he
liked and posting them in Rome for the
public to see the candidate he favored
won the papacy throughout the 17th and
18th centuries in Paris writers created
pamphlets filled with lies and sold them
around for profit these pamphlets were
called canards one canard in the 1780s
announced that Spain had captured a
monster in Chile the monster supposedly
had the head of a Greek goddess the body
of a dragon and the wings of a bat
during the French Revolution canards
were also used for political purposes to
spread fake stories about Queen Marie
Antoinette these pieces of fake news are
believed to have significantly
contributed to the public's hatred of
the Queen which led eventually to her
execution beginning in August of 1835
the New York newspaper the son in order
to gain readership started publishing a
series of fake articles about famous
English astronomer John Herschel having
discovered life on the moon they said
that Herschel using a new type of
telescope was able to see goats unicorns
and beavers living on the moon's surface
the newspaper circulation grew
dramatically after they started
publishing these stories
during the First World War the British
newspapers the Daily Mail and the Times
printed false stories about Germans
taking dead soldiers from battlefields
and grinding their bodies down in
factories to use their facts for candles
and soap this was part of Britain's
larger attempt to get more countries to
join the side of the Allied powers
unfortunately during the next world war
Germany's minister of propaganda Joseph
Goebbels used those fake British news
stories to deny the Holocaust saying
that reports of Nazis committing
genocide were just made up British
propaganda Devils himself facilitated
countless disinformation campaigns in
Germany during World War two he helped
create lies about Jews communists and
critics of Nazi Germany he would spread
false rumors about which countries
Germany was going to invade next
propaganda and disinformation were
central and crucial to Nazi power in
Germany devils famously said a lie once
told remains a lie but a lie told a
thousand times becomes the truth another
regime famous for its fake news in the
20th century is the Soviet Union
disinformation in the USSR got so bad by
the 1950s that a form of underground
illegal dissident journalism began to
develop known as Sammy's duct this
involved dissenters in Eastern Europe
independently writing and publishing
their own newspapers and books by hand
to distribute them secretly in the 1970s
the KGB distributed false information
about the prospect of a nuclear winter -
anti-nuclear weapons groups trying to
prevent the deployment of US nuclear
missiles in Western Europe in the 1980s
the KGB used news outlets to try to
convince the world that the US had
invented AIDS the story was printed in
newspapers in over 50 countries the US
had plenty of their own disinformation
campaigns during the Cold War in the
1950s the CIA placed false stories in
Iranian newspapers in an effort to help
Mohammad Reza Pahlavi become prime
minister of Iran in the early 1980s
during the soviet-afghan war the CIA
planted fake news stories throughout the
Muslim world saying that Soviet
embassies held celebrations
commemorating their invasion of
Afghanistan with the goal of creating
outrage
CIA has a long history of using local
media in many countries to further their
goals much of today's fake news exists
for similar purposes intentional
inaccuracies and obfuscation --zz can be
powerful tools for anybody looking to
manipulate societies for political
purposes the Russian government is
infamous for this in 2007 after the
Estonian government removed a Soviet
world war 2 memorial statue the Russian
government created fake news claiming
that the statue was destroyed in order
to anger Estonia's ethnic Russians in
reality the Estonian government was just
planning to relocate the statue in
September of 2015 the Kremlin forged a
fake video of American soldiers shooting
a car on a BBC investigation found that
the men were wearing the wrong uniforms
and that the video was filmed the near
Russian intelligence office and then in
2016 Russia planted fake news stories
about a 13 year old German girl being
kidnapped and raped by Muslim refugees
there have been credible accusations
that Russia has come up with fake news
stories to influence the upcoming
national elections in France Germany and
the Netherlands in support of their
respective right-wing pro-russia
candidates running this year the Chinese
government is known to use this
information at home and abroad like in
its attempts to fight religious
dissidents and opponents of the
Communist Party and its dealings with
Taiwan and in his recent efforts to take
over the South China Sea in 2001 the
Chinese government employed fake news to
falsely associate demonstrators who set
themselves on fire and Tiananmen Square
with Falun Gong Buddhists to justify
their unpopular persecution of Falun
Gong practitioners this lie was
reproduced by many international news
wires the Chinese government regularly
publishes news articles to inaccurately
convey that Tibetan Buddhists are
flourishing and doing well at the mercy
of the Chinese government when in
reality China actively heavy handedly
torments Tibetans when Kim jong-nam
the half-brother of North Korean
dictator Kim jong-un was recently
poisoned in Malaysia North Korean media
spread fake news domestically and
internationally about the CIA having
been responsible for the murder
North Korea is obviously notorious for
transmitting fake news to their people
and to the world disavowing their
wrongdoings and blaming them on the west
as I mentioned a great deal of fake news
is also manufactured for-profit
commercial fake news outlets include
websites like biz Standard news.com
firebrand left calm red flag news.com
before its news.com now eight news.com
your newswire calm and news breaks here
calm don't visit that one it'll try to
attack your computer with viruses these
sites pose as real new sites but they
just omit total nonsense they rely
primarily on their articles being posted
and reposted on social media sites like
Facebook and Twitter mostly by people
who don't know the difference you get
headlines like Hillary's drunken st.
Patrick's Day Vice President Mike Pence
reportedly addicted to penis enlargement
pills Chuck Berry died few knew he was a
trump supporter Donald Trump proposes
one-child law for Hispanics many sites
like this are operated out of
impoverished areas in Eastern European
countries like Russia the Baltics the
Balkans a study found that during the
2016 presidential election in the u.s.
there were more than a hundred pro-trump
fake news sites registered within a
single town in Macedonia but some of
these sites are based in the US Justin
Koehler is the CEO of an American
company called disinfo media and that
company owns over a dozen right-wing
fake news sites he says that he's tried
setting up left-leaning fake news sites
creating false stories that would
support a left-wing narrative but he
says that sites like that are much less
profitable because he's found that
online anyway right-wingers are far more
likely to take the bait by clicking on
fake stories and sharing fake stories a
recent study by it sews public affairs
confirms this that Republicans are much
more likely than Democrats to
misconstrue fake news as real news the
study found that about 84% of the time
Republicans think that fake news is real
many people believe that news outlets
like
Breitbart Fox News our fake news but
they aren't really these organizations
are better categorized as propaganda
Muse fake news can be propaganda but
propaganda isn't necessarily always fake
news opinion or propaganda outlets like
these theoretically start with true
facts and twist the facts around to
serve a narrative and as long as these
narratives may be fake news is different
RT also known as Russia today is an
international TV network funded by the
Russian government and their messaging
is also controlled by the Russian
government RT has managed to establish
an image for itself as a sort of
credible enough news organization so
that many people take it seriously but
at the same time they're able to attract
American viewers who want an alternative
to so-called mainstream media this plays
perfectly for them and for the Russian
government RT is different from other
government funded media like NPR and BBC
in that they blatantly shill for their
government as a PR arm for the Kremlin
numerous RT reporters have angrily
resigned from the network saying that
they were tired of doing Putin's bidding
RT has reported on the Russia dossier as
though there's no way that it's
authentic they've inferred time and
again that there was positively no
collusion between Russia and the Trump
campaign they've reported on Trump's
claims about the Obama wiretapping
without properly expressing how truly
unfounded the claims are when news
breaks about Trump team members having
met with Russian officials RT frames it
as America merely trying to repair
relations with Moscow downplaying the
aspects about people like Michael Flynn
and Jeff Sessions having lied about the
communication RT is more of a government
propaganda outlet than fake news per se
most of the time a site like Breitbart
shouldn't really be considered fake news
either because it is technically usually
reporting real information and
manipulating the narrative or
selectively presenting facts in order to
send a certain message there are
exceptions we all know that Breitbart
will report falsehoods from time to time
but I think that in theory it's fair
say that it's propagandistic opinion not
actual fake news an opinion isn't even
really news anyway conspiracy websites
like Infowars aren't really fake news
either those are kind of in their own
strange category many of Infowars
stories do contain real information but
they often go off the deep end with
speculation and connecting dots in a way
that makes no sense
granted it's sometimes hard to tell
whether Alex Jones and Infowars even
really believe the stuff they're putting
out there and it does border on fake
news but in principle I don't think it
serves any purpose to label them as such
the fake news moniker should be saved
for stories and media outlets whose sole
mission is to mislead people on purpose
and it's important to single out and
denounce actual fake news that fits the
proper MO that's why it's so
counterproductive the way that Donald
Trump and people in his camp go around
calling everything fake news anything
that doesn't paint a positive picture of
Trump is fake news to him that's why the
term has lost so much of its meaning I'm
not going to give you a message and you
stay counter you are fake dude circa and
you say categorically that nobody know
miss president like that really just
watched the totally biased and fake news
reports of the so called Russia story on
NBC and ABC such dishonesty Russia talk
is fake news put out by the Dems and
plate up by the media in order to mask
the big election defeat and the illegal
leaks the fake news media failing you
know times
NBC News ABC CBS CNN is not my enemy it
is the enemy of the American people
throwing around the term fake news like
this is just ignorant I think Trump is
just trying to get people to distrust
the media so that people won't believe
the media when they report bad things
about him if it finally gets printed
that there's solid evidence of collusion
between Trump and Russia during the 2016
election or that we finally have
evidence that Trump isn't as rich as he
says he is for example by that point
Trump wants to have already discredited
news outlets preemptively so many times
that his supporters won't believe
anything that's reported the Nazis used
a sin
tactic during world war ii they use the
term lugan press meaning lying press to
refer to any media in germany or
elsewhere that spoke negatively about
the Nazi Party Trump supporters at a
rally in October of 2016 were actually
caught on camera yelling lugan press at
journalists
[Applause]
right government intervention can be a
way to fight back against fake news to
an extent in some situations there was
language written into the 2017 National
Defense Authorization Act that asks
federal agencies to combat and publicize
foreign propaganda and disinformation
operations and I see that as a good
thing but when it comes to the idea of
government actually censoring or
filtering speech and journalism that may
well become a slippery slope a road not
worth going down the best defense
against fake news is simple media
literacy knowing how to identify fake
news and propaganda news media literacy
is a major problem in the United States
given how easily fake news is able to
thrive online
ask yourself certain questions when you
come across a news article online was
this article posted on social media by
someone you know who posts many
untrustworthy articles many of us have
friends like that on Facebook does the
website have an odd name pay attention
to the URL does it end with something
weird like dot-com CEO is it an obscure
foreign URL this can also sometimes be a
red flag does the site have very generic
click Beatty advertisements that's also
rarely a good sign look at the websites
other articles to see if the website as
a whole
appears untrustworthy do background
research on the site read the about Us
section of the site is there even such a
section of the site you can also google
the website name and fact check or
source watch after the websites name our
other reputable news sites reporting on
the same story read the comments section
are people calling it out as fake news
look into the author of the article is
there even an author listed what are the
sources do the sources seem legitimate
are there any sources does the
information and evidence in the article
support the claim that is made in the
headline does the story attack a generic
enemy like the media Trump supporters
the left pay attention to the quote
in the story and who said them are there
quotes
who said the quotes are they in context
does all of the information rely on one
groundbreaking or questionable factoid
how much evidence is actually there does
the article engage with anyone who
disagrees
are there many spelling or grammar
errors this can be a sign that the site
has no editors which can also help to
inform us about the website's
credibility not all of these are
foolproof ways of determining whether
something is fake news or not but it
does help to have these questions in
mind as a reader the same if so
public-affairs poll I cited before found
that people who primarily get their news
from Facebook are much less likely to
even be able to recognize fake news and
one in three Americans says that they
see fake news in their social media
feeds on a regular basis we may not
realize it but it is pervasive get your
news from a variety of sources question
and challenge people who post fake news
on social media they may not be aware of
what they're doing and they might
actually appreciate you helping them not
look so gullible in the future maybe do
it in a private message so you're not
embarrassing them publicly in the case
of pizza gate and the leaked John
Podesta emails about comet ping pong in
Washington DC fake news actually caused
someone to show up at a restaurant with
a gun and start shooting this stuff has
real-life consequences but one of the
worst consequences is that everyday
people are being duped easily and many
of those people vote we're only in the
beginning stages of finding out to what
degree Russia interferes with our
politics and in what ways if we ever
find out at all but the fight against
fake news disinformation and propaganda
starts with being able to identify it
and you have to be able to not go around
labeling anything you disagree with as
fake news the way our president does the
boy who cried fake news and we must
actively combat it by adopting and
promoting good habits as consumers of
media understanding how journey
works and understanding how deception
works those might be the most crucial
components of being a functional member
of a democracy